[Music]
what is the modulus of a number the
modulus of a number is nothing but its
absolute value we have learnt that the
absolute value gives us the distance of
a number from zero without considering
the direction in which the number lies
so in other words the absolute value or
the modulus of a number gives us the
magnitude of a number what sign can the
magnitude of a number take the magnitude
of a number can be either positive or
zero it can never be negative yes that's
the reason why we say that the absolute
value of a number is always non-negative
we will be applying this concept to
understand the modulus function the
modulus of a function is written as f of
X is equal to modulus of X so the input
for this function is any real value of x
and the output will be the magnitude of
X now let's say X is equal to five can
you tell me what the modulus of X would
be equal to yes that's correct
the modulus of X is also equal to five
that's the magnitude of this number
similarly when X is equal to zero the
modulus of X is zero in both cases f of
X is equal to X so we say that f of X is
equal to X when X is greater than or
equal to zero what if X takes a negative
value what will f of X be equal to in
terms of X say X is equal to negative
seven
what would the modulus of X be yes it
would be seven so f of negative seven
will be equal to seven or we can say
that f of X is equal to negative of
negative seven why did we write it like
this it's because we had to find the
relation in terms of the original number
which is negative seven with
we can conclude that f of X is equal to
negative x when X is less than zero we
found the relation in terms of the input
so the modulus function can be defined
as f of X is equal to X when X is
greater than or equal to zero and f of X
is negative x when X is less than zero
now we will focus on drawing this
function on the XY plane we know that f
of X can also be written as Y so we need
to sketch the following y is equal to X
when X is greater than or equal to zero
so we sketch the line y is equal to x
starting from zero this is how the graph
will look when X is greater than or
equal to zero
next we sketch Y is equal to negative x
when x is less than zero this is how it
will look so we get a v-shaped curved
opening upwards with the vertex at the
origin we see that the line to the right
side of the vertex has slope equal to 1
and the line to the left side of the
vertex has the slope equal to negative 1
also notice that all the Y values are
positive for the modulus function what
else did we notice the curve is
symmetric about the y axis what is the
domain and range of this function the
domain of this function is R since any
real value can be an input for this
function now if you could tell me the
range correctly it means you've
understood the concept really well the
range of this function is the upper half
of the real number set including 0 this
is how we write it the opening square
bracket tells us that 0 is included and
the closing round bracket tells us that
it can take values up to infinity so
this was all about the modulus function
we'll see another interesting function
in the next video
[Music]
you